this week we are partnered with hellofresh
and Rocket money more on them after the
reaction what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am joined by Roxy strier cuz we
are going to embark on a journey we are going
to park our car at the hasbin hotel today we
don't know anything about it other than some
basic facts it was once a pilot on YouTube by
the YouTube channel vivz pop and now it is a huge
Amazon show man the requests have been coming in
and Roxy is always like I'm the TV girl everyone
knows me as the TV girl I don't know what that
means but I said all right we're going to do
this TV show together we're going to start with
the pilot and make our way through episodes one
through whatever Roxy what were we going to say
you do know what it means I watched 115 shows
last year and the previous year I watch more
TV than anybody I know that is my claim to fame
does that make me the greatest TV Watcher of all
time quite possibly and I'm excited for this one
you told me about it since you said it everybody
I've seen has been talking about it kind of looks
like Harley Quinn the Animated Series to me which
I love excited to see what we're getting into
because we are not hasband yeah I heard is like
a comedy musical I just got the hasbin thing yeah
hasb been we're not hasbin we're currents leave a
like on this video also be sure to subscribe
and click that Bell we got a lot of episodes
to go through I'm reserving the energy and then by
the time we get to the final one it's going to be
wow here thank you to me or prepper for editing
down these highlights I don't know which one's
doing it full length Reaction watch long we sync
with your own copy of hasman hotels available for
our super sex Rejects at our patreon page with
this being the first episode and it's not just
on YouTube is it's available for everyone Link
in the description box do the full watch along
it's pilot not the first episode pilot yeah two
different things you told me okay it's going to be
rough
oh [Music] fun oh how cool very
princess Sleeping Beauty
like satanic that's sad what she's
saying I think I'm going to love
[Music] this could be me I just
knew what a meaningful song [Music] already
that's why I feel like it's Harley Quinn
like f you Heaven this pilot must have come
out before Harley Quinn I think so [Music]
yeah they say welcome to to Hell
welcome to [Music] hell is this actual
[Music] hell love how it feels like an
old film there's a classicness to it
porn [Music] Studios what happened to
Franklin must have died oh my goodness
Rosie took him out waiting
to find him little [Music]
blue it's like if Tim Burton did the Harley Quinn
show yeah this feels like it's going to be a lot
more harder the hotel is within hell itself
she must work there next cleanse 365 days oh
I'm alive I'm alive oh God thanks for the fun
time can you hot stuff die in hell I can't let
it get out I'm offering my service is to Rando
on the street whatever you say ouch oh such an
insult some creative to call me you sack ofly
package horse [__] tell the misses I said hi
schnuck I love how it's drawn like a kid show
and it's got like the whip snap energy of it
too o angel dust let's go you link hey up your
drag show oh God oh my God my drugs damn it I
know the feeling those other cowardly Sinners
dare not hinder my territorial takeover a wise
decision the power of my machines are unmatched
no other demon can compare to the likes of I this
is so inventive giving Dexter's Laboratory
gone dark it's a Cartoon Network element to
it yeah shot them with your ray gun I wish he'd
shoot me with his ray gun this is where Humpty
Dumpty went nothing not a single beast in this
Inferno of suffering will be able to take back
this Empire from my constrictive grasp it's
like a No Man's Land everybody will know the
name of serent Pardon who said that what
did you just say to me you Fried Chicken
[Applause] [Music] fetuses kaboy you looking for
a fight old man oh hell yeah you
want to go Missy well I'm happy to
Oly good afternoon I'm Katie killjoy he got
an actual smoke mask turf war is Raging on
the West Side between notable Kingpin serenus
and self-proclaimed spunky Powerhouse Cherry
Bomb I'm trying to keep up with all the words
here it's really hard demons all over hell are
already duking it out to gain new territory
those two seem to really be going at it nice
they're fighting tooth and nail for that hot
spot and I'd sure like to nail her Hotpot olyp
jackass Tom or should I say no coming up next
the daughter of Hell's own head honcho who's
here to discuss her brand new passion now
she's like little Nikki let's do this just
look at me and I'll mouth it to you come on
vaggie I know what to say her name is vaggy
oh what if I sing a song about it you knew I
was going to say that because I know you but
please don't sing this is serious she's got like
an angel heart better at expressing myself in my
goals through song yeah what did they do to get
to hell they seem like I mean she's the princess
of hell though she seems great the highlighted
bits are the best part uh it's all highlighted
is this a drawing yes that's the happy ending
see I don't think it's that simple just please
follow the talking points we went over and do
not thinging you know she's GNA she's the only
one who's actually born here deserve to be
here I'm Charlie Katie killjoy I'd say it's
a pleasure to meet you but that would be a
lie you can put that away I don't touch the
Gaze how's that working out for you look my
time is money so I'll keep this sh I think
this would be a sick Halloween costume you're
here because Jeffrey couldn't make it for his
cannibal cooking segment oh cool dumb I'm too
rich and too influential to give a flying about
what some tux wearing demon princess wants to
advertise D there a hard AR don't get cute with
me honey or I will [__] dare you it's Charlie
whatever tell us about this new passion project
you've been insistently pestering our news station
about as most of you know I was born here in hell
and growing up I always tried to see the good
in everything around me I knew it Greg I mean
she's a princess it makes sense yeah it breaks
my heart to see my people being slaughtered
every year no one is even given a chance I
can't stand idly by while the place I live
is subjected to such violence they had a chance
is she pacifistic isn't there a more humane way
to hinder overpopulation perhaps we can create
in an alternative way to change Souls through
Redemption so that's what this project aims
to achieve you're giving people in hell hope
a hotel that rehabilitates Sinners and sends
them to Heaven that is just so anti-hel I can
see that going over terribly especially when
people have fun in Hell people like to succumb
to the debauchery she's nuts I figure it would
serve a purpose a place to work towards return
I sing a song babe can't go worse stupid [__]
oh no every single one of you has something good
deep down inside maybe I'm not getting through
to you Lucifer was an angel oh no oh no oh no
I have a [Music] dream about a wonderful
fantastic new hotel happyer to a specific
client inside of every demon is a
rainow every is shiny smile every
creepy hatching Happ [Music] cup around
and then it's like Sweeny Todd Vibes yeah
interesting there's a maob humor to it's
[Music] goth you losers prescrition Dr AB
[Music]
I feel like she's going to go out a really
dark path SC Kiss andon CS you want to be in
[Music] heaven great kind of do you
know who this actress is no idea
it's giving like anak Kendrick Vibes there's
so much Variety in the color scheme and
like the different animation Styles I keep
implementing throughout look how gorgeous that
is I like these little hints of
the darkness in her that was [__]
oh guys I thought there was a 1% chance said
like her I know right think a single denisen
of hell would give two shits about becoming a
better person just takes one you want people
to be good just because what does it matter
you're there forever give it a shot we have
a patron already on the other end of that
what's it matter you're there forever why
try just someone named Angel dustar you what Tom
in any case just not even an accomplishment I'm
sure you can get that hooker to do anything
with enough booger sugar and lose oh wo been
behaved clean and out of trouble for 2 weeks
now breaking news oh no we are receiving word
that a new player has entered the ongoing Turf
War let's go to the live feed it's going to be
angel dust oh [__] oh [__] indeed it looks
like the one who just joined the battle is
none other than porn actor angel dust God
damn it you must feel really stupid right
now it's weird it's so mature but it it's also
feels so nostalgic in the way it's done how does
it feel to be such a total failure yeah well how
does it feel that I got your pen huh [__] whoa
oops hey thanks for the backup Auntie you kid no I
staying at this crappy Hotel on the other side of
town some broads are letting me stay rentree if
I play nice conning the system just some broads
problematic like a Tommy Gun not mine these crazy
[__] are no fun been clean for two Wings pot
shop oh harder daddy [Music] son what
a moment have no class in war the side
remembered is the side with the most style
like how he's an actual serpent is your hat
like alive or something would that make
your hat the top and you the bottom ooh
I wonder if there's like a human like do the
humans evolv into this are there rules or on
Earth did they look like this or wherever they
are I've been making these sex jokes the whole
time and it's obvious you ain't catching on
I mean it's just sad how inventive with the
anatomy it's making me wonder what is down
there you know you're my favorite guy to
party with you know it you ready to finish
this that's what Mel Gibson calls that of
cop oh excellent stuff I want to see your dad but
why is this girl good she's her best friend yeah
but she she's in hell and she's good seems that
right eh you win some you lose a few hundred it
wasn't that bad anyway it was awful what kind
of reputation would I have if people found out
I was trying to go clean throws out my entire
Persona your credibility what about the hotels
your little stunt made us look like aing joke
jez jokes are funny I made you look uh sad and
pathetic super literal don't get your taco in a
Twist baby was that you trying to be sexist or
racist a little bit of both I'm going to kill him
too late but wait would that make me Double Dead
where exactly do I go to double hell that's what
you wanted to know who cares if some got hurt most
of them are ugly freaks look around we got a bunch
ofing harlequinn babies down here you're want to
talk hey this body is Flawless btic man there
is no way anyone is going to want to stay at the
hotel all thanks to you and your you're selfish
[__] does that mean I don't have a free room
anymore we don't know if things are over yet
try to relax vaggie it'll be okay what a name
does it mean what I think it means vaggie is
that her name have you heard that name before
no but what is what do you think it means sounds
like vagina it kind of does sound like that but
I don't really know it's like that combined with
saggy so yeah like a saggy probably a good idea
to get some actual food in this place you know
to feed all the waywood souls you got in here
she's the princess but she's treated with like
zero respect you don't need to be respectful in
Hell she's not the queen hey mom um I know I keep
calling and you must be busy really busy she's so
sweet I know I don't know if I'm going to make
a difference cool color change I could really
use some advice mom she's blue I know it's sad I
think Dad was right about me a I'll stop talking
before this gets long she's the only one who's
so human here bye yeah cuz she's not supposed to
be here Lucifer was an angel if it is the devil
that they're doing says Lilith yeah so I think
it's like a combination of a bunch of Ls yeah did
you watch the show Lucifer no oh it was so good
what's wrong with this guy hey bgie she
wasn't expecting may I speak now you may
Alis pleasure to be meeting you sweetheart
quite a pleasure it's like old time radio
voice what a performance why I haven't been
that entertained since the stock market crash
of 1929 so many orphans stop right there
I'm not going to let you hurt anyone here
you pompous cheesy talk show [__] Lord if I
wanted to hurt anyone here I would have done so
already cool I'm here because I want to help
say what now now he's got an alterior motive
this hotel I want to help you run it but why sh
absolute bottom that's like an anime character
were Montaine lacking Focus aimless whenever we
cut to this perspective shot of him it's sideways
I love this guy he's such a trickster the world is
a stage and a stage is a world of entertainment so
does this mean that you think it's possible
to rehabilitate no you're getting tricked of
course not that's wacky nonsense Redemption oh
the non-existent humanity no no no no what a
dichotomy the chance given was the life they live
before the punishment is this I want to watch the
scum of the world struggle to climb up the hill of
betterment only to repeatedly trip and Tumble down
to the fiery Anarchy right yes indeed I see big
things coming your way a lot of room for character
arcs yeah wait you've never heard of him before
you've been here longer than me audience Cipher
let's go decades ago Alistair manifested in hell
seemingly overnight whoa overlords who had been
dominant for centuries that kind of raw power had
never been harnessed by a mortal Soul before very
Nightmare Before Christmas broadcast his Carnage
all throughout hell just so everyone could witness
his ability how satanic radio demon as lazy as
that is many have speculated what unimaginable
Force enabled him to rival our world's most
ancient and destructive evils this an entity
that was birthed here violent monster of chaos the
likes of which we can't risk getting involved with
unless we want to end up erased you're done I mean
he sounds like he looks like a strawberry pimp do
you trust any man any men men Charlie listen to
me he's a dealmaker pure evil he can't be redeemed
and is most likely looking for a way to destroy
everything like how the ex is over her hair and I
her hair has been over her eye for half the shots
it's interesting but the whole point of this is
to give people a chance to have faith things will
be better how can I turn someone away I can't it
goes against everything I'm trying to do I just
love all the abnormalities to the human design
structure everything just feels out of place so
now you're sketchy as and you clearly see what I'm
trying to do here as a joke on the condition that
there be no trickster Voodoo strings attached so
it's a deal then oh are wicked I uh hereby order
that you help with this hotel for as long as you
desire sound fair H fair enough cool beans
it's enough for him to make trouble not cool
beans my my DEA you know you're never
fully dressed without one what do that
mean you're never fully dressed without
a smile and what can you do my eminite
fellow I can suck you h no great kiting
there's so much precision and calculation
here like everything feels so purposefully
constructed oh my God little pet oh wow Nifty
hi I'm Nifty it's nice to meet you it's been a
while since I made new friends why are you all
women have any men here I'm sorry if that's rude
oh man oh my gosh this is awful nope nope nope no
no wow there's a lot of to deal with that freedom
and weep Boys [Music] full tell you're turning
this to a full attraction right now my friend
I am doing some charity work so I took it upon
myself to volunteer your services I hope that's
okay are you [__] me h no I don't think so be
some kind of biging Riot just to pull me out of
nowhere I'm some kind of clown maybe I ain't doing
noing charity job well I figured you would be the
perfect face to man the front desk of this perfect
voices I can make this more welcoming if you wish
cheap boo is always welcoming but then it would be
a plastic bottle not glass hey go yourself only if
you watch me oh my gosh welcome to the Happy Hotel
guy such a deviant I lost the ability to love
years ago you'll find it you have a dream you
wish to tell oh my God laughable but hey kid what
the hell Charming demon Bell now let's give these
burning fools a place to dwell take it boys wow
what're great neon inside of every demon is a lost
cause D they this on YouTube this is insanity
the most expensive YouTube pilot ever like
simpery this channel just did that I can't believe
that and the voices are amazing
I'm down at this has been home
well well well this is jarring editing do I know
you oh yes you do and this
time I have the element of
surprise I'm so evil I'm so
evil yes Greg all evil people say
they're evil you didn't [Applause]
know
wow it's like a poison ivy thing I mean the
whole thing is kind of like an amalgamation
of a bunch of horror things all in one which
weirdly creates a unique blend well I'm starved
who wants some jumalia wonderful recipe
for jumalia in fact it nearly killed her
ha you could say the kick was right out
of hell oh I'm on a roll the game is set
nowed way to go Vivian yeah wow that was wild
I did get a heads up that they changed some of
the voice actors maybe I don't know if they
Chang all I thought that was unbelievably
impressive I for I had to remind myself that
this was just a a a YouTube thing at first I
could see why it got picked up from just the
first episode here going there you got a show
established perfectly they did a really good
job with their archetypes the trickster comes
in right when he does the main character is
like the hero not an anti-hero I guess she's
just the hero and the leader yeah we've
got her best friend now we've got like
the do debaucherous gambling type yeah that was
really smart now it takes a good what if concept
with your main character to go what if you're
princess of hell had an Angel Heart post credit
scene now will you shoot me with your ray
gun yep it's rewi that let's see what that said
what did it say animation is basically not so
much a technical Implement as like expression
of spirit behind it to see that the spirit
goes into your shooting must be your overriding
ambition honestly that that part's a little wordy
for me it's saying it's more about like the the
expression than the technical aspect yeah those
are the words that are there and uh you picked
up on it you did it yourself look at you you're
an A+ student right there oh Greg BL Rain r ring
reneer I don't know I stopped trying to pronounce
it because I didn't want to do anything bad I
put a little bit of an e emphasis on where the
second I is I just where I heard my mouth was
going thank you to America's number one meal
kid hellofresh for partnering with us it's always
great to partner with people whose Services you
actually use because as someone like me who is
always juggling a pack schedule between filming
and editing finding time for healthy eating can
be a challenge that's where hellofresh has been
a GameChanger for my life with hellofresh I get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorsteps so I
have to step outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable key word I recently
tried their delicious barbecue pineapple flat RADS
and their zucchini pomodora Panet bake both were
mouth watering delicious and fit perfectly with
my pescatarian lifestyle pescatarian fancy and
asking my friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a meat eater
again people I know I've really recommended their
lemon parsley chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it and the fuo chicken faito tacos
regardless hellofresh menu has something for
everyone but of course it's not just about the
food it's about saving time to not having a wait
in line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what I
love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support
the channel and also support you know having
a new lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle
in the year 2024 go to hellofresh.com reex free
and use code reject free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast item
per box while the subscription is active free
breakfast for life for hellofresh.com reject free
use promo code rejects free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy and let's
keep enjoying those movies and shows all right
reject Nation let's get real for a moment running
this channel is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for the
channel and my personal life can be overwhelming
that's where rocket money has been a financial
Lifesaver for me even before I ever partnered
up with them like I said I've been very fortunate
to be working with Brands whose products I already
use so it's a win-win for a walk but it can be a
win-win for you too cuzz there's a reason I use
them rocket money is a personal finance app that
simplifies managing money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and crafting a
budget that fits your specific lifestyle for
someone like me who can easily lose track of
expenses throughout every single day of the
month it's been eye openening to see where I was
overspending stuff I don't use that I kept paying
for especially apps man I was way too many apps
rocket money does the heavy lifting by analyzing
your spending then customizes notifications to
help you stay within your budget goals it's not
just about saving money it's about actively seeing
and feeling your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly subscriptions
too so many free trials I signed up for that
I forgot to you know get rid of before the free
Tri was done making it super easy to cancel the
ones you don't use couple of clicks and you're
putting money back in your pocket telling you
have you ever found hidden subscriptions or pay
for services you forgot about because rocket money
is a huge asset in helping to uncover those and
even negotiate some of my bills down with like
20% so if you're ready to take control of your
finances and there's no better time than now
because it is the beginning of the year check out
rocket money money and see how much you could be
saving stop wasting money on things you do not use
so to help support the channel and help support
your wallet visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users and has
helped save its members an average of $720 a year
with over $500 million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident they'll do
the same for you that's rocket money.com rejects
your bank account will thank you yeah I thought
that was excellent I I mean the the animation was
of course Sublime because it's got like this flare
of retro vintage also like futuristic so it's like
throw it's it's it's amalgamation of like a bunch
of different time periods with goth infused and a
bunch of different types of uh interpretations
of hell all infused into one whil also being
nostalgic like you were saying you know Tim burden
Cartoon Network you know like I didn't get Cartoon
Network growing up but I watch shows like I'm
familiar with the animation like Powerpuff Girls
and Kimpossible I watch a lot growing up I'm
pretty much Kimpossible today yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely yeah sure and uh yeah you say like
Dexter's Lab but it has that kind of like energy
so you could feel the the inspiration behind it
and as well as the pass like this this is like
an achievement of a passion project because I I
was convinced I was watching the first episode
from Amazon Prime and I had to I had a little
moment where I got pulled out like no wait a
minute this is still the you this is the YouTube
one this is I I I did not expect the YouTube one
to feel already like I was watching a show on a
streaming Channel as popular as like Prime video
and yeah we normally we talk for like so long
because mainly do movie reaction we're going to
keep these short because we got like several of
these to go through but Roxy what did you what
was your first impressions I feel very similar to
you I think that it makes perfect sense that this
almost has a 100 million views on YouTube I mean
what a great awesome pilot to something that now
I'm really curious to see about they did a great
job setting up their characters it looked really
great it sounded interesting I like the premise
of this I want to know if it this is the age-old
question can people really change yeah um and
we know nobody can change if they don't want
to but as somebody who has spent her whole life
changing I know people can change and so we're
about to see what may or may not be Redemption
arcs not everybody can do it some people can and
that concept to me is at the core of this which
is why I'm so interested in it that's true like
the the actual setup of what the hotel represents
where you got the dueling aspects I I I'm terrible
with names it's going to take me I probably will
remember everyone's name by the yeah I'll probably
remember everyone's name by the final episode well
there was that one girl whose name you mentioned
mult uh oh Viagra V vag what's her name vagi vagi
yeah I REM my word there vagi uh yeah yes say so
conf our main girl the princess yeah princess of
hell yeah yeah vaggie trickster I'm giving them
nicknames yeah just whatever uh one word uh
subjects Lin we could have about them just to
make it easy to distinguish them but yeah I mean
her setup was was interesting because this I this
idea of redemption in hell is is a fascinating one
to me like I grew up Judaism doesn't have hell do
they no no well Catholicism does so I grew up with
uh Pink Floyd Pink Floyd has hell I mean hell is a
concept that has exceeded Beyond Christianity at
this point um but I what I I'm curious if there
are like actual rules established or is it just
something we go with when you're looking at the
anatomy of stuff that I like the displacement
of things like so much of the hair would go
behind the eyeballs or just like certain designs
everything always felt like it was off and out of
place like Anatomy was was strangely structured
yeah some like some people's legs one's longer
than the others there's like hearts in the eyes
black eyes like uh the hair length all choppy and
stuff definitely it looked like some people that
had the crap beat out of them before they got sent
to hell and whatever state maybe you die in is the
state that you exist in here or once you get here
there's wonkiness that takes place and that's just
how you live yeah was like the snake sent to hell
or did it was it a human that over time it became
the embodiment of of serpent like being like this
is what their evolution is so I like that concept
but the concept EGS the eggs too yeah were they
were they bad eggs that just went to hell you
know or were they really evil babies they exact
oh yeah we can get really twisted about it um
what did that baby do what did that Baby D to
deserve to go to hell well the the idea of like re
rehab in Hell there is like the question of like
what is the purpose like does the re what does
the rehabilitation gain you do you get out is
it a ticket out of hell well they don't know and
that's one of the cool things that the princess
is saying you know we have a population issue
here and so she's doing this because everybody's
disappearing and people are just getting wiped
out and so I think she's trying to deal with
population control and her Theory seems to be if
she can rehabilitate people then they don't have
to be in Hell anymore which you would think would
either send them back to maybe would send them to
heaven but nobody knows that that's what it will
be that's just her Theory it would be interesting
to see if season one covers that yeah yeah I I do
get curious about how some of the rule if if there
are rules at all you know or is just the wild west
down here in the sense of like when people die in
in this world of hell are they just do they cease
to exist forever can you actually die already in
hell if you're already dead like what what happens
there well she they've already mentioned that some
people are gone so clearly either they died or
they're just missing yeah that's what I mean like
what is the definition of death down here because
I actually get the impression that some people
probably just like roll with it and other people
like ourselves might question it and because I
feel like the show has more on its mind than what
is the the surface impression I mean it even ends
on this this text which hints at a lot of subtext
that the show is is delving into because you got
a great you got a great characters very nuanced at
the center of it all and then with all the amount
of lore and detail that they put in through like
every frame whether it's like the background or
the the musical numbers we talk about that the
musical numbers were amazing because it feels
old school but um everyone still has their own
unique kind of genre or flare to everyone who got
a number that fits perfectly ATT tuned to their
voice like not every song sounded the same they're
all distinguishable mhm I think it's a great pilot
that's like a that's like a real pilot I thought
this was like just going to be a Pitch thing but
this felt like a genuine first episode right right
it's not like uh you know uh Always Sunny which
you and I love but always sunny they shot it on
iPhone so for their pilot they had to re-shoot the
entire pilot this is like a full formed you could
have seen this on Amazon pilot yeah dude we got to
watch the rest mhm you you you down yeah oh my God
yeah all right well I'm down let's get down with
it Roxy yeah yeah man I think I would thrive in
hell but it's the thing is like there's got to be
a population that wish that there has to be some
people there who what you can't expect me to sit
next to you after you just told me that you would
thrive in Hell how but thousand thrive in hell I
mean if you're there you might as well make the
most of it cuz there's got to be you might as
well redeem yourself and try to get to heaven
Greg we're on two different sides of this coin
well there's not a guarantee about that I mean
if you're already there there's never a guarantee
that you get to heaven but you just try to be the
best person you be this is why I'm never going
to hell and this is why you are already there I
mean but if you can like steal and kill with no
consequences wouldn't that be fun that's why we
have Grand Theft Auto video games so you think
you can tell I don't know I feel like there's
a fun from Hell the thing about is everyone here
Blue Sky from Pain wants to stay at Hell there's
got to be some people who are like why did I
come here I don't deserve to be here you know
some people because at this point that means
everyone has accepted why they're here there
there got be like weak people here who feel
like they can get out of hell wish you were
here see we're on the same page I'm vibing with
you man we're vibing right now okay well should
we Vibe on over to episode one I'm Gonna Keep
delaying it I feel like I've said we're going
to end this video like so many times but I feel
like let's just extend this my personal H all
right he won't let me go to episode one let's
go to episode one see you soon reject Nation